okay so we'll be starting in couple of
minutes
um
and few of the participants have
introduced uh yourself in the chat box
and I'm also curious to know do you have
any specific research interests Within
bioinformatics
aishi says she wants to do metagenomics
approach environment
foreign
I'm monitoring the chat let me know uh
what are your research interests with
respect to my informatics
are you
um still looking for a particular area
of research or do you have a particular
idea in your mind let me know in the
chat we'll be starting in five more
minutes
in the meantime
all right so let's start with today's
session so hello everyone a very warm
greeting to one and all my name is
and I would like to welcome you all for
the very first session on introduction
to biomatic Dynamics this training
program is designed for everyone
including students who don't have a
background in bioinformatics life
science researchers and the objective is
to introduce topics and examples to help
participants understand omic's data and
the use of bioinformatics in life
science research
in today's session we will gain a brief
overview about the educational materials
and projects as well as the T by info
platform platform that you will get
access to as a part of the program
and before we begin with today's webinar
for those of you who are joining for the
first time let me also take a brief
moment to introduce you to the team
behind the program we are a us-based by
Informatica company who is working with
multiple academic and Commercial
collaborators to develop easy to use
analytical tools and our mission is to
make bioinformatics more accessible
and as a part of the program students
will have access to the omics logic
training that have been completed by
over 24 000 participants from 187
countries in over 300 workshops this
training has been completed by
participants in six different
specialization plants that includes
oncology infectious diseases Precision
medicine Neuroscience data science or
biomedical data
students will also have access to the
omic storage resources which which takes
a combination of training modules data
analysis tools curated project data sets
and interactive sessions with mentors to
give the student a clear path of the
blooms taxonomy pyramid and no matter
what the user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is omic's logic is going
to be a very useful tool for gaining a
baseline knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of large data
set an introduction to basic coding
languages like R and Python and even
beginning a data analysis project
and this also comes with an actor to the
Omega Target courses which includes
courses on bioinformatics Precision
medicine
multi-ombinant that consists of genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and
epigenomic as well as data science that
makes use of bioinformatics using R and
python as well as chemical chromatic and
example projects of different fields
which you could learn from and replicate
for your research work
and another important resource that you
get access to is the T by info platform
users will be given directions to access
the T by info platform for bioinformatic
processing and Analysis of data and this
platform includes demo pipelines actual
data management and Analysis Cloud
infrastructure to run the biomatic
pipelines and different stages of
analysis are performed in different
sections on this multiomics platform
so now to view the various courses and
example projects and student projects
you need to first sign up on the omics
logic learn portal for that let me walk
you through on a brief demo on how you
can sign up
so I'm pasting the link in the chat box
for the participants to sign up on the
omixological platform where you will be
able to gain all the access to the
various courses that I was showing to as
part of the program
so for those participants who are
signing up on the omics logic learn
portal for the very first time uh you
can sign up either using uh either one
way that is enter your email ID and
provide a password you can click on the
create an account option that you see
here and enter your name and email ID
and a password
this is one way how you can sign up
another way you can sign up is you using
any of your social media handles this
could be your Google Facebook Apple
account GitHub account or even Twitter
and for those participants who have
already enrolled for the program and who
already have an account on the portal
you can simply click on the login now
option that you see here and simply
click enter your email ID and password
that you use to register on the portal
and click on sign so I'll pause for a
couple of seconds for the participants
to sign up and I'll walk you through uh
the demo on what are the various courses
and exam projects that are there
so please let me know in the chat I'm
monitoring the chat box for your
responses once you have signed up on the
portal please today yes
and if you already have an account on
the portal please put a done in the chat
box
[Music]
aishi has signed up uh pankaj has
already signed up Charles has also
signed up what about the rest of you
guys
okay we have a lot of responses
Shay Rosen
if you are facing any queries you can
let it let us know in the chat as well
so I can say that a lot of the
participants are signing up so uh please
uh continue to put your responses in the
chat box you're preparing constraints
I'm just going to sign in uh using my
login credentials
so once you sign up on the portal you
can see this um interface where you'll
be able to see the various courses and
example projects that are there so if
you scroll down below you will see a
search bar that says looking for a
specific course so in this tab you can
search for a specific area of interest
that you have so let's say you are
interested in oncology so you can simply
enter oncology
and that will show you the various
courses and example projects that are
related to cancer and I can see that a
lot of the participants might be
interested in introductory
bioinformatics
so you can simply enter the term
bioinformatics and that will also show
you the various introductory courses
that are there in bioinformatics so you
can browse through at your own page and
have a look at the various courses and
example projects that are there on the
portal so for now
um I'm going to show you how you can set
up your profile on the portal for that
you can simply click on the tab that
says welcome back with your email ID
so once you click on this you will be
able to see your account settings
so here uh you'll see an icon that says
profile click on that and that will show
you how you can edit your profile so as
you can see here the very first
important feature that you need to um
update is your profile image as well as
your name make sure your name has to be
in proper capitalization and not that
all your
name is going to be in capital letters
and also you have the option to link
your social media handles so in my case
I have linked my LinkedIn account and my
orc ID and another important feature
that you must update on your profile is
your bio so here is an example bio that
I have that is I have mentioned my
educational background and my research
address so you can also do the similar
for your bio and you can also see
various tab options in your profile
under the activity tab the program
mentor and the community manager will be
tracking your learning progress
and under the courses tab the courses
that you are currently completing will
be displayed so for in my instance uh in
my case I'm currently completing
transcriptomic analysis in Python
and finally once you complete a project
and publish it on our potent that will
be displayed under the project
and this is the programs tab that you
will be able to get access to your
program information so in my case you
can see I have enrolled for two programs
one is precision medicine and one is for
the research Fellowship finally after
the completion of your courses the
required assignments and quizzes you
will be able to receive your certificate
for the course under the certificate
step and another interesting um tab that
I want to show you is the project step
so once you click on this you will be
able to see the various student projects
that are there that have been published
on our portal so the projects uh topics
range from oncology infectious diseases
Precision medicine machine learning and
so on to so you can have a look at all
of these at your own pace so that was
all about setting up your profile and
navigating through the courses and
example projects about it so now uh we
can start with the today's session for
that I'd like to park on the stage to
shubham who will be playing a short
video recording uh by the program so
over to you
thank you srigori I'm just sharing my
screen
perfect
uh could you confirm is my screen is
visible
see
all right so I'm just like starting the
session
this program is an introduction to the
field of mathematics or uh in this
program we will discuss the changing
landscape of data-driven research in
life sciences and the opportunities that
come with wide widely accessible High
throughput Technologies and
computational methods for analysis for
annotation of such detailed data in
biomedical research and Parma Industries
and elsewhere we will also discuss
various data types we will discuss
emerging Technologies and their impact
on Healthcare environmental Sciences
Public Health
and Etc
so let's learn more let's learn more
about the program and the curriculum of
this program and what will different
sessions cover and how are they
structure and what are the resources
that we are going to be accessing in
order to understand or in order to use
these programs uh yeah when you travel
to the school
so this program has 10 sessions and in
these sessions you will see a broad
applications of
Next Generation sequencing while
statistics as a tool for Big Data
analysis
so we also have lots of practical
assignments in which we will be learning
about the logic the time difference
analysis to see how these data science
methods can be used to study or used to
be applied to biomedical research in
general so when you complete this
program you will also be able to plan
how to take what they have learned and
how to apply
to an independent research program
using the Logics you
you're using the tools to enter YouTube
and using the methods we cover in this
so first let us start with
not be the research so one of the
primary driver driving process for the
necessity of bioinformatics is
availability of the data that is
generated in Insurance off so the volume
of data kind of changes the biological
domain to a data driven science compared
to the traditional hypothesis driven
nature of the biomedical research
the data and its availability leads to
the fact that we have some method of
structuring or we have to devise some
method of structuring and organizing
this data to make sense of the patterns
that we are useful
approaches can also impact referral to
methods of analysis and that will help
us in the interpretation of the
biological data in the adaptation of the
biological data with respect to
therapeutical conditions that we are
studying our financial
studying our samples
so what is my informatics and how do we
use it so it can be summarized or it can
be different as a science of
storing lots and lots of context
biological data and analyzing this data
to find new insights which we will use
in many different ways so bioinformatics
in in syntactivity is is fundamental to
many biological wasters and it involves
either biologists who learn information
technology or mathematicians and
statisticians who learn the foundations
of biology
so in short it is a convergence of
biology and data where both are equally
important as we will see in the next few
slides and we will be detailable to this
program
so today's biomedical research
example isn't simply about finding or is
simply about publishing one set of
Services I'm hoping
so just read it and find connections to
all the other uh
modes so it's about finding patterns
it's about discovering patterns in all
types of data and connecting everything
that is out there in the biological
domain to provide new insights that we
can only start if we see or if we look
at a bigger picture so bioinformatics
lets us bring together the data from
lots of different experiments into one
place so we can ask those meat for
questions and find the relations
and communicate to objects so such data
availability from different sources are
rather yeah from these sources have
changed the nature of biological
research it so and we observe that the
biology itself is rapidly acquiring the
characteristics of data science happy
so when this happens or when this
biology uh biomedical research and
biological research
quickly acquires the characteristics of
data science we see this is due to the
billions and billions of data points on
genes and on proteins and other
molecules that are compiled in
other systematically studied so
analyzing this data will lead to more
knowledge and understanding about living
organisms including our health
biotechnology including about resources
for food
like livestock and etc etc so this
course
participants
specifically students biologists
clinicians faculty such effects
so this impacts of data associated
this impacts of data and the associated
of associative methodologies and the
data arrival research makes
bioinformatics for Life Sciences as
prominent as the emergence of computer
for different Industries in these days
so this whole field is based on high
throughput technologies that generate
billions and billions of data
on genes on proteins and other molecules
which characterize the biological
systems and phenomena these data can be
economics genomics epigenetics
transcriptomics and more about this we
will
discuss new detail in the coming slides
and also in this several different
sessions in the program Chinese data are
actually compiled into the positivities
and can be systematically studied and
understood as interrogated to establish
trends for many different applications
so if such data and this such data with
so much volume is available
yes it is available and one such
repository is maintained by the national
Center for biotechnological information
ncbi and for example this ncbi database
has a collection of peer-reviewed
Articles biological data assets and
projects on various topics
biomedical research we would not have
for this as a part of biomedical
research Community we would not have
done anything without referring to the
public database that I wish to Define
so
as you can see in the past several
decades this resource has been growing
exponentially and to give you a scale
that are over something like 80 000
publicly available data Assets in just
one part of lcdi called gene expression
Omnibus which predominantly Source
transcriptomics data or several
different jobs
are submitted by the users like that so
such repositories containing data sets
of thousands and thousands of genes in
each sample with tens or even hundreds
of samples the rate acid for different
conditions
are rich sources from which we can
leverage uh to understand the biology of
the system or
to relate this data with several other
uh oh
GM 700 biology that is available
established foreign
so this program is designed to highlight
the role of big or mixed data that we
discussed right now which is the shaping
the biomedical Innovation where
molecular data is used for precision
Diagnostics Big Data integration and
machine learning are actually
transforming the treatment selection of
the personalization of the achievement
selection and the presence or
publication of inevitable algorithms
allow for unprecedented capabilities
with the block Discovery with the design
of large molecules and Drug repurposing
under every every and each and every
um
aspects of biomedical research has been
elevated in Jupiter usage of this data
and by by Big Data and a bioinformatics
associated with this speech
so this program will cover some of the
important Technologies and the
applications in today's world
new participants will be able to access
actions bioinformatics resources along
with our mental support to get help with
the learning processes and which will
um transform or help you learn the
transformation of biology
so by the end of this you will learn
about the importance of bioinformatics
Concepts and applications various
applications of Next Generation
sequencing the role of data science for
biologies and Industrial challenges
towards uh
industrial challenge
so to get started I would suggest all of
you to go through this collection of
several basic courses that will
primarily introduce you to
bioinformatics applications in
healthcare biomedical research
biotechnology
this will also provide you with the
concise overview of various Concepts
that you need to understand in the
comics biological data access
so in addition to that those for those
of you who are interested in venturing
into coding practices for bioinformatics
analysis in this symptomatic
introduction process will also introduce
you to some basic
so if you already know the basics of
bioinformatics if you know what the
general idea is and you would like to
get the DJ eventually into some
especially
excuse me
animation is running yeah so if you
would like to get more detailed entry
into this specialization charts we have
multiple courses and programs addressing
your needs so in these specializations
you will get resources to learn more
advanced methods of analysis and you
will learn how to extract meaningful
insights from larger big assets using
code free option that will employer that
will actually Leverage The Big Data by
informatics server the turbo bioinfo
server which we will get a lot of
introduction and Hands-On demo to
or you can also choose to understand
this is using a
using application in a coding
environment
so if you want to get more information
on these specialization courses then you
should complete these uh
programs first and then
we need more
motion about these specialization
courses then I would
suggest you to complete this
introduction to bioinformatics program
first then you will be able to decide on
will be able to
focus on one part a couple of
specialization
so after these programs in which we
discuss about the basic data types
skills necessary to analyze these data
types then we have these specialization
options outside this test and these
specialization courses are designed to
introduce you to project Source from
Publications where we take examples from
Publications or publicly available data
assets and we start discussing about the
methods in the context of particular
research question and these are compiled
into example projects under under
different set of ways like oncology in
Texas this is
to these projects allow you to not only
apply the bioinformatics that you
learned technically but also to use it
in a way to conduct the research asking
questions to develop hypothesis and to
translate your understanding of the data
to established a process that will give
you results that you are looking to
address in the area of oncology Etc in
the infectious diseases another cases
because why is this context important
because ultimately the methods were
actually best learned
um if we put it put that into practice
in the context of real case studies so
this is where these example projects
that are prepared by taking publicly
available data assets and um and to
explore them for uh for application into
hypotheses and methods that we will use
this data
so to start with the syllabus or to
start with
this specific
so this is divided in
first topic that you will get interviews
to do is genomics and introduction to
genomics so this program will actually
uh these sessions will actually help you
understand why we should study genomics
so to give you a context this is an
essential subtitude of bioinformatics
and this is one of the major force in
understanding or understanding our
knowledge of associative genetic
variance with diseases abnormalities
so this is developing
um this is a field in which development
of methodologies for DNA sequencing as
well as analysis methods to analyze
these DNA sequence to data and of
genomics data from Next Generation
sequencing technology and um
for example to
compact to uh to relate this analysis to
several different PNA variations and
mutations that can be linked to
phenotypical uh variations of the sample
to lead to the disease and biology and
also to generally lead to abnormalities
that we can observe
comes from the sample that
so this understanding of genetic
Association provided by this genomic
research have great value in medicine
ecology biotechnology many
firemindustries and also in agriculture
so what are we actually studying and how
are we relating that to these
phenotypical associations so we start
with absolute basic like we start with
what is a DNA code and what are we what
is the basic or what is it fundamental
data that we are recording and um
and the variation that we need to
understand so
the variation that we need to understand
is a DNA code changes in the DNA code
when we compare it with a reference
sequence of the
genomic sequence represent sequence of
any typical or how many given day
to go forward on the effect of the
sequence of mutations are or will be
covered in details in in the program
sessions to give you an overview for
example any variation in the sequence
set or in the
sequence that you have sequence for your
sample is compatible
reference sequence cannot be pathogenic
we may have variation that will alter
the look on the functionalities of
specific samples without for example
leading to harmfulness that means we
call them as variations or generally we
call the mass variations or sometimes
neutral mutations but mutation is a
specific term that that we deserve for
associating them themselves with a
pathogenicity or with the harmful nature
or harmfulness of the area variations
are variance that we find in the
sequence right for example in this a
simple graphic only the last
functional form has a pathogenic
mutation because that's interesting and
the fundamental functionality of this
specific uh
so anything that is harmful to the cells
or to the samples are termed as mutation
and sometimes
um when these variations that are that
have insignificance or that does not
have significant harmful levels are
generally called as variance this is an
accepted terminology in this
so how to do this specific analysis we
will again use the G bio info server to
set up web processing and to set up the
analysis or to set up a mapping of these
small range into the reference zero and
to identify with this in our sample
sequence compatible
at the based on available knowledge in
the Publications or public in the
Publications on the literature are
available knowledge in the repository is
common repositories and we can actually
identify
uh changes or variants that can be
related to phenotypical uh conditions of
the sample or abnormalities that we are
studying or the disease biology and this
data can also be subjected to several uh
other post-processing methods with which
we can
um again
extract meaningful information and
insights about the biology
we were generated right performing this
analysis uh methods of genomic analysis
of pipelines are
characterization of variance one such as
this where we can visualize the mapping
of the means of your samples under the
reference sequence that is given in this
way bar since it is zoomed out to a
bird's eye view we cannot read this
separate sequence and we can also
understand the strength of alignment of
your leads to this particular or
specific position of the genome and
these vertical or the bars in uh
analysis and during the course of this
program also we will refer to a lot of
lessons from this genomics course and if
you are interested participants can
check with genomics course for further
information
so our next set of sessions will be
involve understanding of the involved
and covering metagenomics and microbial
abundance analysis so this course is
going to introduce you to bioinformatics
analysis so this three sessions
analysis of metagenomic signals data we
will start speaking about some
some of the sequencing Technologies and
also some of the methods to study
microbes and for example
several different analysis tools for
metadatic studies and we will also see
few examples where these analysis
approaches have been used
human bodies are estimated to make up
more than half of ourselves right and
then diversity is extremely critical
though human health
most of the time these microorganisms
live in harmony with their human hosts
providing a vital functional functions
that are Essentials for measurements
about for example
and they can also enable the work of
immune system they can for example be
linked to
their use of
diversity and we need to Premier League
every health condition as we are
discovering maintenance so today we see
for example in today's research we think
an interventions to manipulate the
population of this microbiome from
several different sources one of the
popular resources is the cut microbiome
with survivorous products such as
probiotics drugs or therapies changes in
the food habits and business products
Etc all of these two
um
and manipulate the microbial population
so that we can live a healthy life
so the the imbalances is very necessary
to address and this is called this
meiosis of the microbial population that
we will get into usable so this this
biosis are imbalance in the microbial
diversity as we know is related to many
modulations of disease biology such as
diseases
services and sometimes to autoimmune
diseases and a lot of other
health conditions like chronic diseases
and Etc Ginger
and also like the ability to digest
important risk factors diabetes or
chronic disease systems Etc and the role
of these that microbiologists
um
is very uh actively to lead to several
uh
um 10 commissions uh
so these associations these promises and
these microwave studies fuel the
exponential increase in this
availability of this data and that is
for example
a significant advancements in on a major
initiatives in acquiring this microbial
metadatics data from several different
parts of the human body so these Studies
have for example
um
I mean data sets that are possible too
to get from our data sets that are
extracted from guard Which is popular
resource and skill run and even
sometimes brain
so these data has written over the past
decade uh United States has actually
spent more and more on microbial
traditionally
not only in the U.S but also in the
European Union in China Canada
for example to give you a context 20
percentage of the human investment or
sorry 20 of the U.S investment in such
research has drawn to
two major phases on both human microwave
projects right and this human microbiome
positive speeding the resources the data
that is necessary to understand the
diversity and their pattern involving uh
human uh
Wednesday
and it is because of this huge
investment of capital and it is because
of these huge availability of the
microbial
this data today we know that uh for
example um
uh we know that the endogenous human
microbial communities contributes to
several typical metabolic to several
important physiological and
immunological functions right they
include maturation of the immune system
they include food digestion energy
generation and nutrition extraction in
general they include metabolic
regulation and control of the fat
storage we also improve detoxification
of the harmful chemicals and they are
definitely important maintenance of the
skin and they also are
associated with the
mission
and
in this reality of infection is also
stravid off right in the context of the
planet
so in this sessions or in these sessions
we will actually introduce you to
several tools that will help you to
perform population analysis
function then it is going very fast okay
so the population analysis and these
tools will help you to identify microbes
without for example prior knowledge of
what the sample contains right and these
um these Technologies and these analysis
methods which will enable us to perform
sequencing based examination of these
microbial community
as actually indeed become useful and the
powerful Truth for generating new and
novel hypothesis uh relating microbial
propagation to several operations
conditions as we have been discussing
and match this these sessions
will also introduce you
uh hello everyone uh I would like to um
pass on to us
could you please thank you so much I
think we had an audio trouble uh we did
not have the audio uh well played so we
uh email the participants the recording
of the session so that they can revisit
the topics that uh were supposed to be
discussed although we have taken up most
of the topics now I would like to share
my screen and discuss about the program
let us see what all sessions do we have
and uh how are we going to conduct this
program in a hybrid way where we will
have live sessions conducted like q a
sessions with recorded Mentor sessions
that would be shared for training and
also uh how we will be uh taking care of
the resources the resources access and
also the portal coursework and the T
bioinfo server access that the users
would get
so right now I'm on the uh
bioinformatics program page I'll just
put the link in the chat box
yes so on this program page you can find
the complete session schedule of the
program if you scroll down you can see
each one of these sessions the days for
which these sessions are scheduled today
we have the first session the topics
that would be covered and they
Associated online resources that
includes lessons and courseworks on the
omics logic learn portal that you have
to go through as a part of each and
every session and if in case the
participants are not able to attend the
live session or the live tuna session
because of their prior commitments then
they can go through the recording of the
session that would be uploaded under
each session as a part of the specific
session that you have to take up
now these resources are all hyperlinked
so if you click on the resource you will
be redirected to the specific lesson of
the course that you are required to
complete as a part of this specific
session so this is the first uh course
which introduces you to the field
bioinformatics
what is bioinformatics what is the role
of big data in bioinformatics what is
the role of bioinformatics in healthcare
and what is translational bioinformatics
today we wanted to introduce
um people from different fields
biochemistry microbiology biotechnology
to the field of bioinformatics and also
introduce you all to Big Data so that
you can begin with the study of comics
in the next session we will discuss
about genomic data studies we will
introduce you all to genomics DNA
variants and mutations and following
which we will take up the session on
metagenomics
after metagenomics we would be focusing
on microbiome functional bacterial
community and then discuss about
transcriptomics our motive behind
conducting this program is to discuss
students researchers to the field of
omics which includes genomics
transcriptomics epigenomics metal
genomics and also discuss about how
machine learning and data science tools
and techniques could be applied to
analyze and visualize different types of
comics data to extract biological
insights out of it after the
transcriptomic studies we will take up
the session on single cell
transcriptomics which is one of the most
evident means that the researchers are
now working on and then we will discuss
about different tools and techniques
that could be used in the field of data
science and machine learning different
types of machine learning unsupervised
and supervised analysis and finally
we'll also discuss some case studies to
understand how the different concepts
that we learned could be applied to
answer a research question or frame a
research question and work on it so that
would be the flow of the different
sessions in the program and we have the
dates mentioned the topics and the
resources that the participants are
supposed to go through
so this was about the program schedule
and now I would like to pass on the
stage to uh Miss bashtra to talk about
the registrations
over to use brush
thank you so much sonalika
I'll just share my screen and I'll
quickly uh navigate you all through the
steps of
registration
okay just a moment could you please
confirm if you can see my screen yes
Persia screen is visible perfect so
sonalika has already shared the link to
the program page with you uh in the chat
box and once you open up the link uh you
will see like the program has already
commenced today today was the first
session and in this first session the
agenda was to tell you about the
different resources which we have the
demonstration of the like communication
channels either slack telegram or maybe
WhatsApp groups Etc and then tell you
about the different platforms which
you'll have access to and what all
Topics in curriculum which we'll be
following throughout the program
throughout the 45 day 60 days or 90 days
10-year program
so about the registration process when
you'll scroll down a bit more you will
find three different tenures I'll just
quickly change the pricing here first
into USD
okay so when you scroll down you can see
here are three different tenures in
which anyone can uh like register or
enroll for now the question arises what
are the common resources which you'll
have access to and what is the
difference between the 10 years the
three different annuals which you all
can see on the screen so the first
question that is the common resources
which will have access to is online
tutorials project examples coding
sessions session recordings online
Mentor Support Online technical support
certificate after completion of the
program and then you will have access to
the example Cloud pipelines on the t-bio
info server so these are some of the
common resources which everyone would
have access to whosoever is enrolled in
the program uh
now the second question is what is the
difference between the three tenures
when we talk about the 45 days tenure so
in the 45 days tenure you will go
through with a full-fledged training
related to what is bioinformatics what
are the different terminologies used in
bioinformatics what is different
Healthcare application where
bioinformatics is being used how
bioinformatics is being used in
translational research then moving
further with multiomic studies genomics
transcriptomic single cell a
metagenomics microbiome Etc and then
correlating it with some machine
learning and in the end case studies and
projects example so whatever you have
learned conceptually and then a
practically Hands-On so you will be
applying that in a real life application
by converting them into a an independent
research project
so the 45 days is just a full-fledged
training
now when you talk about 60 days you will
have two different opportunities one
would be one-on-one Mentor sessions so
for example if we are going through with
any of your module and you get stuck
somewhere and the next live session or
the live q a session is maybe next week
or so and you want to immediately
connect with a mentor get your queries
resolved and move further with the with
the recordings or the associated online
resources or any kind of assignment so
you will have access to one-on-one
Mentor session in 60 days and not in 45
days in 45 days there are access to the
group discussions in group like sessions
then in 60 days you will be having
access to uh the draft or like you can
draft a research proposal presented to
Mentor for the evaluation purpose so the
first 45 days would be your training
part and the next 15 days would be
devoted to drafting a research proposal
presenting to the mentor Mentor would
evaluate Mentor will guide you give you
a feedback expert feedback would be
there uh if any amendments would be
required to make it more validated and
then after that if it's validated you
can start working on your research
proposal and then convert it into a
full-fledged research project
now in 90 days you will again have two
different opportunities one is obviously
the one-on-one Mentor sessions and
second is you will have an opportunity
to draft your own independent research
project so the first 45 days again would
be devoted to your trading part and the
next 45 days would be devoted to your
draftmen of the independent research
project literature review data set
finalization proper experimental design
then analysis interpretation biological
statistical and then the manuscript Etc
so this structure and or this
um
this will be done in your 90 days 10
years so once your project is completed
you will also have a like a chance to
earn a certificate of excellence in 90
days now the now talking about the
outcomes so the first outcome is
obviously the research publication when
we talk about in 90 days and then is a
poster presentation competition in
different research Symposium and then
International Conference and also a v
Pine biotech we organize biannual omics
research Symposium where uh anyone uh
maybe like a student a high schooler
with an example like good research
project or a graduate a postgraduate or
a like a researcher or a faculty anyone
who is interested and they have a pro
like project in their hand they can
develop a poster present they can
Showcase in our research Symposium we
have a proper competition and you can
earn like exciting cash prizes also
so uh we'll be telling you about it in
coming few days so this like the omics
resource Symposium is in March so we
have started the registration also we
can share it afterwards through like the
mails now this was about the 45 60 90
days resources you will have access to
now coming on the pricing part so for uh
USD like for those who are living in us
maybe Canada Etc places the pricing for
45 is dollar 150 the 60 days it's dollar
300 and for 90 days it's total of 450
and right now we are providing
scholarships up to 50 percent so those
whosoever is interested please ping
their email address in the chat box and
our representative will mail you
regarding the steps to register with a
particular coupon code so please pay
your email address in the chat box now
if you are from India or any other
country you can change your uh currency
accordingly if you are from Brazil you
can change it accordingly if you are
from European country or so you can
change it in Euros then uh for Indian
it's an INR and the pricing for for
Indian people is for 45 days it's 7 500
INR 60 it's 10 000 INR and 90 it's 15
000 INR and for Nigerian people
it's for 45 days it's naira
50 000 for sixty it's naira nine uh one
lakh and then for 90 000 or 90 days it's
naira one lakh fifty thousand so yes
again we are providing with scholarships
so those whosoever is interested please
ping the your email address in the chat
and we'll connect and mail you
accordingly and provide you with a
better solution
so this was about the resources the
tenures the pricing Etc now we have
other alternative method also like bank
transfer for PayPal is there and then
you pay option for Indian Community Etc
is also available
so if anyone is facing any problem
regard related to payment process they
can mail us at marketing logic.com or
they can ping me on the official number
that is plus nine one nine eight seven
six one three four one two zero
hopefully I guess maybe shubham has
already pasted the information in the
chat box
now I'll just quickly show you the
procedure of the payment
how you can proceed further for example
if someone is interested in 90 days you
need to Simply click on buy now button
and you will be redirected to the
payment page the checkout page
if there is any coupon code you can
simply write the coupon code here click
on apply button the coupon code will be
applied successfully a pop-up message
would uh showcased here on the screen
then you need to fill out the user
details your name your email your phone
number your country occupation
organization Etc click on the check box
and proceed with the payment method
either PayPal or stripe Etc and
the payment would be processed it could
be done and you will receive a receipt
automatically
if you'll pay through the portal so this
was about the payment checkout and how
one can do and proceed with the payment
so we will be sharing the section
recording with everyone because of the
technical issues and you can see the
suggestion recordings by tomorrow in
your inbox
secondly those who are interested and
want to continue and want to know what's
there in the second session about
genomic variance DNA mutations Etc so
please hurry up and enroll yourself and
so as to leverage different resources
and get to know more about
bioinformatics and multiomics think
uh thank you and if anyone is having any
question related to registration
resources scholarship Etc please feel
free to Ping in the chat box thank you
over to you srigori
thank you so much we have a query from
Rosen does this program include
practical training like how to run NGS
analysis
uh so yes uh rosan uh this program will
include practical Hands-On we have a
platform shubham could you please paste
the platform Link in the chat box we
have a platform called the bioinfo
server
and in it's an AI based Cloud pipeline
where there are different toolkits or uh
Roseanne and uh you will have particular
data sets Etc which you can like upload
if you'll have excess of 60 or 90 days
and you can run those pipelines and
analyze those results interpretation
like analyze those results come up with
some biological or either like
statistical interpretation if you're
enrolled in 90 days you can come up with
a proper research project also so this
program includes both conceptual uh
theoretical plus practical part
so the omex logic learn portal which I
just showed you is for your theoretical
and conceptual knowledge and then the
platform which I am talking uh right now
is for your practical Hands-On part
thank you so much and uh Rosen is also
asking can you show the price in INR
yeah sure I'll just once again share my
screen and show the pricing in INR
so um
in just a moment it's loading now I
guess uh my screen is visible
so the pricing in INR is I'll just
quickly change
so the pricing in INR for 45 days is 7
500 for 60 days it's INR 10 000 and for
90 days it's INR 15 000 and again I'm
telling that yes we are providing with
scholarship
so you can mail us or you can connect
with me on the official number SRI gauri
will once again paste the details here
in the chat you can save the detail
somewhere and you can connect with me
and I can tell you the appropriate
scholarship which you'll have access to
oh thank you so much Purge and we do
have
um some queries about scholarship so
that shubham is asking all of you to
share your email IDs in the chat so that
he can forward you the details and uhmi
is asking can you please email us the
information about resources available to
us
uh National I guess you are a program
participant and you have enrolled in
this program if I'm not wrong and
definitely our project manager or a
community manager would email you the
resources available related to this
program uh by tomorrow
perfect uh and Rose and Roy is asking
thank you do I have to install any
softwares for for performing analysis uh
no no Rosa you don't have to install any
software uh particularly to do the for
performing any analysis we have our own
platform you will when you'll enroll in
this program we will be providing you
with uh some credentials a username and
a password you need to just login in the
platform and uh everything like we will
properly guide you how you can use how
to run a pipeline Etc so no other
install softwares you need to install
thank you so much parish and uh shubham
has shared a step-by-step
um manner how you can enroll for the
program and then Charles is asking I
would like to know about the feasibility
of enrolling in more than one program
uh so Charles like I would suggest uh if
you can like give minimum of two to two
hours per day or so
um one to two hours per day for each
program then definitely you can enroll
more than uh one program I would say not
more than two because then it would
become more difficult for you to uh like
simultaneously work on both the programs
and attend sessions and complete the
assignments Etc on time so either one or
two would be uh better and so that you
it becomes more visible for you to
complete the sessions of both the
programs and maintain the pace so
regarding if I'm not wrong I guess
you're talking about the scholarship or
so also in terms of visibility then yes
definitely if someone is enrolling in
more than two programs we will be
providing with a good uh part like
scholarship and also for the Nigerian
community
uh we are already providing with the 50
scholarship so I guess uh like 50
scholarship is it's it's a partial
scholarship and it's
great enough
and uh we have one more query from
nashmia uh will we be getting the
recording of these lectures yes yes
you are a program participant and uh you
will have access to this program page
and you will be finding each and every
session recording here on the program
page itself
if I'm not wrong you are a program
participant I guess
and we have one final query in the chat
from Nelson does this webinar issue a
e-certificate
uh sorry does this webinar issue an
no the webinar doesn't issue an
e-certificate but yes if you'll enroll
in this program you will definitely own
an e-certificate
all right uh that was all in the queries
in the chat so if the participants have
any further queries let us know and
we'll be happy to answer
uh Rosen is asking I am not a
participant yet will I get the video
lecture
so yes uh you will definitely get the
video lecture for this
uh session first session as first
session for every program it's open for
all so that everyone should get a
glimpse of what we'll be including in
terms of module or something uh
throughout the program so it's free for
all it's accessible to all and we'll be
sharing the session recording with
everyone
so you will also receive it
all right so that I guess that was all
the questions that we have and if no one
has any further queries we'll be ending
today's session
all right thank you everyone for joining
today's session and those of you who are
not enrolled for the program yet kindly
and gold and we hope to see you all for
the next session as well thank you
everyone have a great day
thank you sorry thank you everyone bye
take